all right hi again i'm going to make a
tutorial now on how to get this rocket
dock up at top of your screen
um now obviously i'm using windows vista
i have windows vista home premium going
and i'll just open this to show you
this to home premium uh 2.2 gigahertz
processor three gigs of ram and a 512 my
graphics card okay
um so this is how i got the rocket dock
i will open this i'm uploading a video
this is my internet browser
and just go uh to google and search
rocket
rocket dock
um
again this is freeware i do reviews on
freeware and the first result will be
rocketdoc.com
go ahead and click on it and it'll take
you to the rocketdoc.com website
what is it well it's a smoothly outlet
smoothly animated alpha blended
application launcher that's just what it
is it's an application launcher it's
very very simple
you go to the
you simply go to the download link
the download tab at the top and you can
download an earlier version of it but i
would suggest downloading the latest
version
um this is what i'm running right now
the 1.3.5 version
and once you download it and install it
it'll put it on your desktop and you'll
have it to
mess around with so
i right now i have a few things in my
doc not a whole ton but i've got a few i
have
um my internet applications and ccleaner
which i show you guys i did um
actually i'm uploading right now
no that's not it but i just uploaded a
uh review on ccleaner my office
documents and a photo editor called [ __ ]
my email client caller bird
skype this is just communications this
other tools this is for my scanning on
my
all-in-one printer this is media and
this is what was already on it um so
in here we can edit our docs settings
uh there are several tabs it's very
simple first of all we have the english
the it's basically the language you can
record in
and what language you can
run this whole application
selected by that startup
um i don't want to minimize the dot
because i actually like the live
previews that happen in
windows vista so i leave that
i have running application indicators
which is that little dot that little dot
that little dot and
lock items which means i can
accidentally drag one out if i didn't
launch then i could drag one
um
when you have running application
open running application instance that
means when you click on it it's going to
open in like a quick launch it's going
to open the one that was
already open
uh icons
i'll select average quality
okay
um
that basically just dictates how long
it'll take to load and a buffer the
animation um when you change opacity see
it's pretty much opaque right now if you
change it to 50 it's it's
um it's really transparent until you put
your mouse over which is a cool effect
but it takes a little cpu
zoom opaque that's what happens when it
turns opaque when you zoom
uh size which changes the size of the
icons the overall dock and then
the zoom effect and the zoom pixels are
the size it becomes when you put your
mouse over it
so that's cool that you can change that
also the width is how much it what when
you mouse over it
and duration which is how long the
animation takes
i have mine at the top of my screen you
can also have it at the bottom which is
down here like the mac os 10 dock you
can have it on the left
and a lot of people have it on the right
i didn't put it because i have a sidebar
open sometimes
so i just leave it at the top which is
standard and you can also bring it off
center or even off of the edge
uh which is you know interesting
i'll keep it
i'll keep it up girl
census
okay
uh that's for position for style
uh there are tons of themes that come
with it and you can even download more
which i will show you hopefully
um you can hit the get more and you will
find it from where you downloaded it
which would be
from your internet browser
and
you can also change the fonts that show
up what it says windows media center but
underneath you can change that font and
there's your preview right there
behavior this is simple um you can have
it actually bounce when you click on it
or i just you know have it darken for an
instant like that
um
that's basically it 1.3.5
and there are forums you can update it
instead of just
deleting it and reinstalling rocket dock
is developed by a fanboy and fangirl on
osx
well that that explains this look
all right um you can reset it to the
defaults anytime if you screw something
up and you don't like so here's what it
looks like when i click on it
simple and now it has a running
application instance and it opens up my
windows 7 calculator
um notepad it just clicks and you have
the thing running
so i like it
also
when i unlock the items here
you have the opportunity to drag it out
and move it to a different spot
and still have the little black arrow
here
and you can move wherever you want
also you can take something and drag it
out and it'll just poof in a puff smoke
and i can always add a separator where i
want it
and i can move that separator around
etc
now
about add-ons
i will show you add-ons really quickly
um this is done so i can go
to google
and go type in cams no not cam studio
i'm still on my last tutorial type in
rocket
dock again
and
uh there's usually an add-ons thing here
it's rocketdoc.com again
i'll try to post a link in the
description go to get
and this is really cool because uh you
can change different icons like you want
for certain things i'm going to show you
an add-on that i got recently here's an
icon pack
here's open office uh
uh icon
a c cleaner icon which i use the
standard sheet cleaner icon
um you can add skins and also a thing
called doclets so i'm going to show you
um
stack dots
since i can here i think i have enough
time
let's see yeah we're good so
i unlocked it so right now i can right
click here
and add an item
save to add a
clock doclet
that's the clock i really don't like the
clock but whatever i can skin it later
or i want to add a stack doclet this
adds a little transparent icon if
there's nothing on it when you click on
it yet
but
i will go to icon settings
here is something cool
you can change the icon that it looks
like and that will change this and then
you can change the folder where it is
directed to so i'm going to go
and find
this is
uh
i don't know 18 wheels of steel so it
opens that and what icon do we want
we want a rocket okay
so now we have a rocket and what happens
when you click on it it opens that
folder you saw that animation
that is a pretty cool animation it is
what uh it's basically one of os x
animations it flies out and i can also
use icons to change that
to
a
fan
instead of a grid which will send it all
the way down my screen like that
if i don't like that i can always go
icon settings like i don't like it and
change it back to grid
also if not all the things are here that
you want to see just hit open in folder
and it'll open it right up and you can
browse from there
with the
just
so i i like it i write open the mix and
i get all my muscles in my trucks
it's pretty cool
um but i want that so i just poof
disappear lock items so i never
accidentally delete one again
um personally i like it it's really it's
really handy i don't feel like going to
start typing safari every single time
or starting and looking for
thunderbird there it is you know it it's
just it's a fa it's faster
it's faster and i just want to show some
of my music i'll just go in and open it
up and there it is
so
um
that thanks for watching my tutorial and
comment rate and start to subscribe
thanks
you